[Música]
Hola Yo soy Natalia Cabrera parada y
esto es aquí América el magazine de
France 24 para revisar en profundidad
las noticias y las historias de nuestro
continente y esto es lo que veremos hoy
Guatemala elige al sucesor del
presidente conservador Alejandro yamatei
los candidatos críticos al sistema
fueron excluidos y la mayoría de los 22
que aún están en la contienda son
conservadores entre ellos los tres
favoritos
en escombros fue hallado el submarino
desaparecido en el Atlántico Norte que
iba en una excursión turística a ver los
restos del Titanic que a su vez naufragó
en 1912 los cinco tripulantes se dieron
por muertos
y a un año de la anulación del fallo de
versus White que protegía el derecho al
aborto a nivel Federal en Estados Unidos
dejó su acceso a decisión Estatal Dos de
cada cinco mujeres en edad reproductiva
viven en estados que prohíben
interrumpir el embarazo
y vamos de inmediato a Centroamérica
específicamente a Guatemala donde está
la cifra de la semana 22 es el número de
candidatos presidenciales en la primera
vuelta una contienda polémica debido a
que los aspirantes que realmente
representaban un cambio respecto al
gobierno conservador de Alejandro
yamatei fueron inhabilitados como la
líder indígena Telma Cabrera Carlos
Pineda quien lideraba las encuestas y el
hijo del expresidente Álvaro arzú
Roberto arzú las instituciones son
señaladas de participar en una maniobra
para preservar un régimen de corrupción
pues algunos de los candidatos que sí
permanecen no deberían poder competir
debido a que violan condiciones
estipuladas en la Constitución como no
estar vinculados con grupos religiosos o
no ser familiares de antiguos dictadores
veamos el informe
la dificultad de elegir en Guatemala 22
candidatos se presentan este domingo a
la primera vuelta de las elecciones
presidenciales un número que había
podido ser incluso más alto el tribunal
electoral bloqueó a varios aspirantes
Empezando por una figura de la izquierda
la representante de los pueblos
originarios Telma Cabrera o El Hombre de
negocios Carlos Pineda quien lideraba la
intención de Voto lo que para algunos
mina la confianza en el proceso no
aceptan a otros por cuestiones
administrativas Entonces definitivamente
este este proceso electoral esta estas
elecciones tienen más sombras que luces
después del golpe de estado de 1954
Guatemala sólo ha conocido prácticamente
gobierno de derecho este año 19 de los
22 candidatos son conservadores entre
ellos Los favoritos la ex primera dama
Sandra Torres que prometió distribuir
comida a los más necesitados así como
disminuir los impuestos a los productos
básicos
Sully río Sosa hija del ex dictador
Efraín Ríos montt apoya la instauración
de la pena de muerte y defiende la
propiedad privada el centrista hermon
mulet que promete ayudas y apoyo a las
personas de la tercera edad y a las
madres cabezas de familia los tres están
en contra del aborto y del
reconocimiento de los derechos de la
comunidad lgbtiq más gracias a Dios para
enfrentar a las pandillas varios
candidatos Proponen Igualmente una
política similar a la del presidente
salvadoreño bukele criticado por su
acumulación del poder
no digo de Dictadura por el momento pero
sí autoritario modelo Nicaragua por
ejemplo la persecución contra medios de
comunicación contra periodistas contra
operadores de justicia
contra políticos la reciente condena del
periodista José Rubén Zamora a seis años
de prisión por supuesta corrupción ha
dividido las opiniones muchos denuncian
que se trata de una decisión política
samura ha sido un crítico del presidente
saliente Alejandro yamatei bajo cuya
administración Guatemala cayó al lugar
150 de la clasificación mundial de los
180 estados más corruptos
vamos ahora a Estados Unidos la guardia
costera anunció el jueves que encontró
unos escombros en la zona donde se
encuentran los restos del Titanic e
informó que el submarino turístico que
estuvo desaparecido durante casi una
semana con cinco personas a bordo sufrió
una implosión catastrófica previo al
hallazgo trascendió que en 2018 el
entonces ingeniero de Ocean Gate la
empresa a la que pertenecía el
sumergible envió a los líderes de la
compañía un informe en el que criticaba
el diseño del casco y su capacidad para
resistir las intensas presiones de las
aguas profundas el episodio terminó con
su salida de la compañía vamos a ver el
informe
22 de junio el sol se asoma en el
Atlántico indicando que la hora cero
llegó las 96 horas de reserva de oxígeno
que tenía el titán el submarino que
exploraba los restos del Titanic con
cinco tripulantes a bordo desaparecido
desde el 18 de junio se agotaron el
jueves 22 de junio cada ser humano es
diferente algunas personas pueden vivir
con más presión otras con menos no hay
mucho que hacer para que el oxígeno dure
debes estar tranquilo pero cuando estás
estresado tu consumo va a ser el doble o
el triple significa que las 96 horas no
están garantizadas
una expedición programada para ocho días
que salió desde la isla de Terranova en
Canadá los dos primeros días Estaban
programados en la embarcación Horizon
Arctic hasta llegar al punto de
inmersión la cual toma dos horas en
bajar hasta unos 4.000 metros de
profundidad allí el submarino tenía un
recorrido aproximado de 4 horas por los
restos del Titanic que naufragó en 19 y
luego debería tomar otras dos horas para
regresar a la superficie
titán logró su primera expedición en
2021 y desde entonces lleva a
millonarios al fondo del océano con La
Única condición que no sufran de
claustrofobia es el único submarino que
transporta civiles en una cápsula en la
que apenas alguien puede ponerse de pie
con pocas provisiones de comida o agua
un baño de emergencia y comunicaciones
inestables una expedición criticada por
la falta de pruebas técnicas Como hizo
Chris Brown un desertor de este último
viaje
partes del submarino que había visto en
las pruebas de las Bahamas parecían un
poco de mala calidad usaron tuberías
industriales como lastre y un control de
Xbox como timón pero lo que realmente me
disuadió fue que se negaron rotundamente
a Obtener cualquier tipo de
certificación los hallazgos indican que
el titán implosionó por la presión sus
tripulantes quedaron enterrados en la
oscuridad perpetua del océano
seguimos en Estados Unidos pero
cambiamos de tema porque se cumple un
año de la decisión de la Corte Suprema
de Justicia de anular el derecho al
aborto a nivel nacional tras revertir el
fallo del emblemático caso raw versus
White que desde 1973 protegía la
interrupción voluntaria del embarazo
hasta la semana número 24 de gestación
los magistrados argumentaron en el caso
dobs que la Constitución no hace
referencia al aborto y deja en manos de
los gobernantes estatales la decisión al
respecto Y eso es precisamente lo que
sucede desde Entonces miren el aborto
está prohibido en 13 estados si no está
disponible en Wisconsin donde no hay
proveedores siete estados más restringen
la interrupción del embarazo en función
de la cantidad de semanas que una mujer
ha estado embarazada y algunas
restricciones llegan hasta las seis
semanas antes de que muchas de ellas lo
sepan
en la Unión Americana hay 65 millones de
mujeres entre los 15 y los 44 años
edades en las que se calcula pueden
quedar embarazadas más de 28 millones de
mujeres en dicha edad reproductiva viven
en estados donde el aborto está
prohibido no está disponible O está
restringido y 2 millones más están en
los estados donde el aborto está
disponible pero las restricciones están
pendientes de aplicar esto significa que
muchas mujeres que buscan interrumpir su
embarazo tienen que viajar largas
distancias
para entender el problema conectamos en
Ciudad de Panamá con Carmen Martínez
ella es directora asociada de
estrategias legales del centro de
derechos reproductivos y portavoz del
caso dobs contra Jackson wimens Health
organization que dio paso a la anulación
del fallo Rover versus White bienvenida
aquí América y Quiero preguntarle cuál
es el peligro que enfrentan las mujeres
y las niñas que deben ir a otro estado
de Estados Unidos para interrumpir su
embarazo
Desde que la Corte Suprema de Justicia
de los Estados Unidos emitió su decisión
en el caso de Ops alrededor del 20% de
la población de ese país quedó sin el
acceso a un servicio esencial de salud
como lo es el aborto en su propio estado
estamos hablando de más de 70 millones
de personas en todo el país además de
enfrentar inmensas barreras que implican
esos traslados forzados que según
estudios por ejemplo implica Que corran
mayor riesgo de violencia intrafamiliar
que además se vean exacerbadas las
deudas situaciones por ejemplo de
desalojo también implica que se ven
vulnerados sus derechos humanos
incluyendo su derecho a la salud y es
que muchas de las mujeres que debían
acceder a un aborto por motivos médicos
son originarias de México donde también
cada Estado es responsable de la
legislación siendo la prohibición la que
domina sin embargo esta semana la Corte
Suprema de Justicia mexicana estableció
que cualquier persona con capacidad de
gestar podrá solicitar un Amparo de
inconstitucionalidad de artículos que
penalicen el aborto en leyes de los
diferentes estados mexicanos esta
determinación facilita el camino hacia
la despenalización en todo el país
cambiamos de tema y nos vamos a Brasil
porque empezó el juicio contra el
expresidente Jair bolsonaro ante el
máximo tribunal electoral que lo señala
de abusar del poder por difundir a
través de los medios de comunicación
públicos información falsa para
descalificar el sistema electoral en la
campaña para los comicios en los que se
enfrentó a Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva
desde Sao Paulo la corresponsal de
France 24 Valeria sacone nos cuenta las
claves del juicio
el expresidente
enfrenta quizás la semana política más
difícil de su vida porque según la
mayoría de los analistas políticos de
Brasil estaría a punto de ser declarado
inelegible por el Tribunal Superior
electoral la razón una reunión que
convocó el año pasado en julio antes de
las elecciones presidenciales con
diplomáticos extranjeros en ella criticó
las urnas electrónicas sin aportar
pruebas poniendo en duda todo el
funcionamiento del proceso electoral la
fiscalía general de la justicia
electoral dice que se ha tratado de un
abuso de poder hecho con intenciones
electorales Eso es para influenciar el
voto de los electores y precisamente por
eso pide que sea declarado inelegible
durante ocho años bolsonaro solo podría
volver a ser candidato en 2030 ya con 75
años su defensa reconoce que la reunión
estuvo fuera de tono pero alega que se
produjo antes de las elecciones y que
por lo tanto no sería delito bolsonaro
Mientras tanto ya hace declaraciones en
tono de resignación dice que en caso de
ser condenado quiere seguir activo en la
política y de hecho los analistas
políticos más conocidos de Brasil creen
que el resultado ya está cantado serán
seis jueces contra uno y s1 será lunes
martes el juez evangélico que bolsonaron
nombró para el tribunal supremo el mismo
que podría pedir una vista preliminar en
este caso el juicio si suspendería por
un periodo de hasta dos meses algo que
no desea la parte de la derecha por qué
porque ya es hora creer en algunos
sectores de la derecha de presentar el
nuevo nombre el sucesor del bolsonarismo
ya que no hay esperanza parece para el
futuro político inmediato de bolsonaro y
así comenzar a emplacar un nombre en un
país Brasil que nunca sale de la
precampaña electoral y para la despedida
hablemos de comida el restaurante
peruano central fue elegido como el
mejor del mundo en la lista de Worlds
Fifty best restaurants el restaurante
había ganado la distinción también en
2022 cuatro restaurantes de Lima
llegaron al listado consolidando a la
capital del Perú como la capital
gastronómica del mundo 12 restaurantes
latinos en México Brasil Argentina chile
y Colombia también llegaron al listado
el evento es considerado como los Oscar
de la comida Gracias por ver esta
emisión de aquí América en la producción
estuvieron Giovanni agudelo y en la
producción de invitados Nataly Quiroga
Sigan viendo France 24 y France 24.com
[Música]